what is it like because I'm I'm a huge
Colin coward fan what's he like as a guy
and just like what's it like working
with him because you guys had a great
run before you went to speak for
yourself and kick your own thing off
Collins the best he is
I'm a radio nerd too
I appreciate this he's a huge prepper
yeah so he does a two-hour prep show
before the three-hour show right so
there's a lot of prep he's very thorough
he wants to make sure he has the
graphics he wants to support what he's
talking about he wants to make sure that
he has the sound he wants to support
what he's talking about he wants to make
sure he has the statistics he's looked
up you know the historical stuff that
goes along with what he's saying he
really talks through all of the topics
so his ability to you know stretch a
subjects the way that you're talking
about and continue to have the
conversation with you the listener but
by himself it's crazy I mean his brain
works differently to be able to do that
anyway but it really also helps that he
preps a lot he doesn't like to waste air
time so sometimes sometimes it depends
on the show obviously but we'll do a
little banter back and forth whatever
about you know being in wine country or
whatever I'm going to Utah but it's
never
too long you know we don't let that
conversation be the conversation we're
having in the segment right he always
brings it back to okay what do we want
to get to here we're going to we're
gonna get to Aaron Rodgers here like we
can we can go a little bit off to make
sure that people know that we're human
beings but we got to talk about what we
planned on talking about he's very very
serious about the show he feels like
it's disrespectful to the audience to
not be prepared to do a show I love it
so that's what that's really what makes
him great and able to do such a big show
because three hours of content is a long
ass show for sure in our business that
is an insanely long show and he does it
as his show so he can do all of that by
himself if he needs to obviously uh for
you because you have your your solo
podcast I haven't done this podcast yeah
but I have one for several years but
while you were doing uh the Cowher show
you had your show right um was the
upside for you to leave the Skip and
Shannon show which is the biggest show
on the network to go to Colin was it
because you were able to have like
because you had your own segment every
day were you able to kind of like you
were able to get your [__] off you know
yeah it was at the upside or like what
made you want to make that move it was
partly you know obviously a different
role in a more expanded speaking role
now when I first went to Colin it was
still just you know the news updates
he'd bring me in here and there but like
it took a little time for us to build up
the muscle of him being able to just
lean on me when he needed to like it's a
trust and chemistry I had done the show
a lot so I already knew the Beats of the
show because I was filling on her a lot
when I was doing Undisputed so we
already knew how to do the show together
but what the show was going to feel like
together just took a little time and us
doing it from home during the pandemic
actually really helped us a lot because
we just had to talk that's all you had
to do that's all we had to do you have
nothing else going on yeah but for me
you know my goal was always to be in the
role that I'm in now and
it was important to me to always keep
growing in the business so I did two
years of Undisputed and I felt like I
had you know mastered that role and
there were you know I'd kind of Hit the
ceiling of how much better I was going
to get at that role and I was ready to
try something different and you know get
into a new challenge in a different type
of show so it was never that like I
didn't want to work with them or
anything like I love Skip and Shannon
and love doing that show it was just
time for me to go to a new role do
something new yeah and similarly that's
that's why I made the jump to to speak
after Colin